11e arrondissement au beau milieu du
boulevard de ménilmontant une allée et
baptisé en souvenir de ce drame qui
avait créé un émoi national le 23 mars
2018 mireille knoll 85 ans rescapé de la
shoah était retrouvée morte tuée de 11
coups de couteau dans son appartement
c'était une promesse faite par la maire
de paris en 2018 anne hidalgo a rendu
hommage à l'octogénaire un repère office
eu lieu pour celle de feu parisienne par
une v1 visiteurs touristes qui
voudraient aussi rendre un hommage à
mirelle knoll et faire vivre sa mémoire
sur la plaque cette inscription mireille
knoll lâchement torturées et assassinées
parce que nés juive le caractère
antisémite de ce meurtre avait été
retenu par les deux juges d'instruction
en juillet 2020 cette cérémonie était
également l'occasion de délivrer un
message le combat contre l'antisémitisme
doit nous rassembler c'est un combat
profondément démocratique et républicain
et au delà des clivages politiques qu'il
était important que chacun marque bien
cette volonté de lutter contre toute
forme d'antisémitisme
aujourd'hui et demain car
l'antisémitisme est un poison
l'antisémitisme est un venin qui divise
profondément et qui est un danger pour
l'avenir de nos sociétés démocratiques
les meurtriers présumés doivent
comparaître ce mardi devant la cour
d'assises de paris un procès très
attendu par la famille de mireille knoll
nous on attend une justice implacable
j'espère qu'ils vont être condamnés
et qu'ils n'auront même pas le droit de
sortir avant la fin
avant la fin de de leur punition
il ne mérite pas de profiter de la vie
ces gens là un meurtre contestée par les
deux suspects qui seront entendus ce
mardi pour le début d'un procès qui doit
durer jusqu'au 19 novembre